chez la civilisation continue à marcher
comme elle le fait elle va se casser la
gueule quand je suis toujours intimement
persuadé la civilisation court à sa
perte
c'est le cri d'alarmé de rené barjavel
un auteur renommé pour ses romans
d'anticipation et de science fiction
en 1971 il estimé avec gravité que la
vérité première la vérité la plus grave
et malheureusement le fait le plus
difficile à combattre que le malheur de
l'humanité
chez d'être trop nombreuses selon
barjavel la surpopulation en plus de
provoquer de terribles famines
entraînera un mal encore plus grave
la pollution dans 20 ans ou dans 25 ans
le risquant de voir ce qu'ils seront
encore là de voir les hommes crever
comme on voit aujourd'hui les poissons
crevettes quand une quand une règle chez
chaque attendu mann heat et les crever
de trop de pollution et de trop de
technologie car depuis ses premiers
écrits dans les années 1940
rené barjavel dénonce l'interconnexion
croissante de nos sociétés imaginez ce
qui se passe chez toutacoo l'énergie
charrette
c'est l'écroulement ch est le
commencement de la décomposition chez
comme un corps ou le chant circulent
plus une vision apocalyptique de
l'avenir même si barjavel veut rester
malgré tout optimiste il y aura toujours
un espoir pour sauver l'humanité celui
de donner maintenant comme but primitif
à toutes les recherches
l'homme est l'entente la communication
et l'amour rené barjavel meurt en 1985
ses thèmes de prédilection reste plus
que jamais d'actualité à l'heure où les
questions écologiques et technologiques
occupe le centre du débat
[Musique]